did you guys see what happened with the
musk with the fed yesterday and twitter
did you guys read that story or no
the fed fed investigating elon musk oh
yeah i heard about this that open
investigation into ilamas if you if you
make it a little bit bigger to read it
u.s government has reportedly opened an
investigation to musk's business dealing
surrounding his recent 44 billion dollar
purchase of twitter the sec is probing
musk's tardy submission of public that
investors must file when they buy more
than five percent of a company's shares
the disclosure functions as an early
sign to shareholders and companies that
a significant investor could seek to
control or influence a
company so he was late 10 days which mo
believed to save 140 million because the
price could have been higher if the
public knew about his ownership five
percent the company the case is easy
it's straightforward danny the
university of pennsylvania accounting
professor said but whether they're going
to pick that battle with elon is another
question so you're already seeing how
scared people are of this guy owning
twitter they're losing the uh so go to
associate press yesterday i i don't know
if you guys saw what ap said yesterday
about musk with uh pulled that up about
the fact that here's a a elon musk who
is fighting for
freedom of
speech but at the same time he was a
person that targeted no not targeted his
attacked a lot of people
uh on uh twitter and do you want that
guy to be the leader it's a very it
doesn't even make sense
the idea that that's a contradiction
that he's like look this guy believes
you should be able to say whatever you
want on twitter but also he says
whatever he wants on twitter it's like
there's no contradiction there look
everybody's freaking out because
basically what happened with the the
rise of the internet and social media is
that the establishment lost their
monopoly on information and this is why
they were all freaking out for years and
this culminated in donald trump being
elected president in 2016 where the
entire corporate press was telling you
you're not allowed to support this guy
and then 63 million americans were like
no we're going to
and so the response to it then was that
they the congress
hauled all the heads of the social media
companies in front of congress
explicitly threatened them that if they
didn't crack down on fake news and hate
speech they were going to regulate them
and all of this they basically got them
to all roll over and this led to like
this kind of censorship regime on social
media where basically people get kicked
off and this was really useful to them
during the covet stuff i mean all of the
doctors who were like against the
lockdowns and against the mandates at
challenging the vaccines they all got
banned we had robert malone on and yeah
mcculloch
and these guys these guys and then of
course they went after rogan when he had
malone on like he's always he's ready
right
misinformation guy so now you have this
guy this the richest man in the world
who's saying well i'm gonna buy maybe
not the biggest but certainly one of the
most influential social media companies
and i'm saying no no more of these rules
so they're all freaking out about it but
it got announced right after when he
bought uh when he first bought into
twitter that they were looking at um
investigating tesla now they're looking
at investigating this deal yeah now the
federal government's going to crack down
on him because he's committing the crime
of threatening to allow american
citizens to communicate with each other
it's really bonkers
that's the tweet right there if you pull
it down a little bit so they can see the
logo above elon musk boasts that he's
acquiring twitter to defend freedom of
speech but he has long used the platform
to attack attack
those who disagree with yes no that
would be an example of of people saying
what they want
like like what david said so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]